nothing strikes more fear among
Venezuelans than seeing this special
action force or fires on patrol in
low-income neighborhoods armed with
assault rifles and with her identity
hidden this elite police force
originally formed to fight crime has
become synonymous with extrajudicial
executions Jose camara lost his 18
year-old son
Anja Gabrielle eight months ago the day
he went to visit a woman he was seen in
an area where the fires was patrolling
he says the boy was shot at point-blank
range inside her house and made to bleed
to death
I don't know why they killed him but I
know that the fires first tortured angel
because they thought he belonged to a
gang of delinquents
my son had no criminal record and wasn't
involved in their business I want the
girl to make a statement but she's too
frightened mr. Camillo has joined other
relatives of people killed by fires who
are demanding justice they show us the
photographs of young men who police say
were confronting them this is an
extermination the fayus arrived to kill
to steal everything in your house with
total impunity these were brothers first
they killed one than the other there's a
case where they killed all four people
in one day
often they kill all the men in a house a
report by the UN High Commission on
Human Rights describes the Faiz as a
para police group that carries out
extrajudicial killings and has called
for to be disbanded this mural is an
homage to just one of the hundreds of
people allegedly killed by the thighs in
this part of Caracas alone according to
the locals some of them may have been
involved in criminal activities others
not but the common denominator according
to people who say they are too afraid to
speak to us on camera is that they were
murdered in cold blood according to the
Venezuela observatory of violence an NGO
specializing in murders the homicide
rate in 2019 was 60 point 3 for every
100
and inhabitants the highest in the world
but what most stands out is that 1/3 of
the killings are reportedly carried out
by police we asked Venezuelans chief
prosecutor about the allegations which
he says are exaggerated cientos cuatro
800 officers have been accused of
homicide torture cruel and inhumane
treatment illegal arrest or entry among
other crimes yes it's a lot but it
reflects Authority and judicial action
unlike in Chile Colombia and the United
States but the vast majority of cases go
unpunished
Alexis leader is still fighting to bring
three fires officers under arrest for
the murder of his brother to trial
despite constant death threats he says
the Western air or two-sentence be tiga
you can have 800 under investigation or
even charged aware are the sentences
they operate with impunity president
Nicolas Maduro responded to the latest
report on institutional violence by
congratulating Phi's for its hard work
[Applause]
the UN High Commissioner for Human
Rights suspects the government is using
the Phi's and other security forces to
spread fear in order to maintain social
control if so it seems to be working you
see a Newman al-jazeera Caracas